sometimes i forget just how good
kingsman the secret service really is
and since its prequel the king's man was
just released i decided to re-watch the
original film and it was fantastic based
on a comic book called the secret
service written by mark miller and
illustrated by dave gibbons kingsman is
an ultra violent and highly stylized
love letter to the james bond films of
the 70s and 80s it's absurd it's
shocking and it's just incredible
kingsman has to be one of the most
bizarre yet still amazing movies
released in the 2010s but not many
people seem to be talking about it if i
had to describe the film with a simple
phrase it would be an absurd masterpiece
welcome back to stream in the galaxy i'm
rocket riley and taryn edgerton and
colin frith's kingsman holds a special
place in the list of some of the best
movies released over the past decade
this film seems to be a collection of
simply brilliant scenes with a
remarkable score and incredible fight
sequences from the bar fight to the
underwater training scene this movie
kept me on the edge of my seat the
entire time the film starts us off with
an awesome introduction scene and song
dire straits money for nothing setting
the tone for the rest of the movie it
brings a light-hearted and comedic tone
to the spy thriller genre while not
sacrificing any of the beloved nostalgic
espionage the movie also gives a great
setup within a pretty short amount of
time eggsy unwin whose late father
secretly worked for a spy organization
lives in south london seemingly headed
for a life behind bars however secret
agent harry hart recognizes eggsy's
potential and recruits him to be a
trainee in kingsman's secret service
meanwhile the villainous richmond
valentine launches a diabolical plan to
solve climate change by instigating a
worldwide killing spree valentine played
by samuel l jackson is actually quite
great with an understandable yet flawed
character motivation this movie plays
heavily upon its absurdity whether it's
through a ninja assistant with swords
for legs world leaders heads exploding
in fireworks samuel l jackson with a
fake lisp drinking vintage wine while
eating mcdonald's or a spy umbrella with
a built-in shotgun this absurdity is
used to perfection playing out in some
amazing action-packed scenes including
the initial bar fight scene where colin
firth explains that manners maketh man
but my absolute favorite scene of the
movie takes place in the kentucky church
let's pause here though i could probably
make an entire video on this one scene
since it's likely one of the most
memorable four and a half minutes of any
spy movie ever released if you'd rather
not re-watch this somewhat disturbing
bloodbath skip to this time
otherwise let's dive into it in the
scene harry kills over 40 people in many
horrific yet brilliant ways while
leonard skinner's freebird plays in the
background these four and a half minutes
of brutal chaos took a total of seven
days to shoot since it involves so many
different moving parts but the film's
director matthew vaughn was able to pull
it off with near perfect pacing and
editing the scene's editing is really
what holds everything together since
there's so much madness happening all at
once the original cut of the scene was
actually over 7 minutes long with no
cutaways but then the producers decided
that there should be several cuts to
other members of the cast so that the
audience could catch their breath
between all the chaotic takes happening
in the scene and these cuts were
actually hidden quite masterfully the
scene is also one of very few to
correctly implement shaky cam the subtle
vibration of the frame makes it seem
more chaotic and exciting while in other
scenes that would have been completely
unnecessary lastly the choreography was
perfect using the church's environment
and all of harry's spy gadgets to their
full potential surprising the audience
in some cases at one point after harry
runs out of ammo he pulls apart his gun
so he's able to stab an assailant with
it and he can also be seen using the
church's incense as a weapon with sparks
flying each time he hits someone
although the scene seems like it might
be completely out of control it actually
took one of the highest levels of
control to pull it off everything went
right with this scene the right director
the right editor the right choreographer
and the right actor colin firth the
leading actors for the film were almost
perfect although it was weird to see
alfred play the part of one of the bad
guys and luke skywalker as a college
professor taryn eggerton's character
eggsy had a pretty good level of
character development throughout the
film changing from a lower class
criminal with no respect for people who
consider themselves gentlemen to a
world-class spy with a greater
appreciation for upper class gentlemen
and an understanding that he may not
know everything kingsman actually has a
similar storyline to the first men in
black film where a young man is
handpicked and taken from his daily life
to become part of an underground
organization that takes on global
threats although the film was somewhat
slow in the second act thoroughly taking
its time to set up the final set of
scenes it pulled it together in the
final act returning to its exceptional
pacing lastly i want to talk about the
film's score one which refreshes sounds
reminiscent of classic spy franchises
like james bond composers henry jackman
of captain america the winter soldier
and matthew margerson of x-men first
class teamed up to score the film and
they achieved exactly what the movie
needed a light-hearted and quirky spy
theme with room for serious
action-packed sequences although it had
just a couple of flaws kingsman is still
an absolutely absurd masterpiece if you
enjoyed this video and want to watch
another movie review check out my video
on spiderman no way home also i post a
new video every week so don't forget to
subscribe like this video and thanks for
watching
[Music]
you